I'm not sure who needs to hear this,
but abortions and miscarriages are very different things.
Anytime an election is about to happen,
I see so much misinformation about this topic.
A few years back, I had a miscarriage,
and after a little while, I had to go get a DNC procedure done.
I remember the doctor walking in with all these tools and forceps,
and he had to remove my baby piece by piece.
Was devastating. It was horrible,
but it was something that needed to happen
because my baby was already deceased.
The DNC procedure
is something that is often used in late term abortions.
So what people will do is they'll say,
if you are voting against being able to do that procedure
in the later stages of pregnancy,
whether or not your baby is alive,
you must be against it at any point.
And you were there for hurting women who are having miscarriages.
It seems like such an obvious lie,
but a lot of people fall for it.
To me, it's kind of like the term burial.
It's like if we lived in a different world
and a group of people came along and said,
you know what? We need to ban burying people alive.
You can't do that. It would be extremely dishonest for people then
to go tell their friends, did you hear about this law?
They wanna make it
where you're not even allowed to bury your loved ones after they die?
Anymore, yes,
technically it is the same process,
but doing it to somebody who is deceased is very,
very different than doing it to somebody who is still living.
That's how it is with abortion and miscarriage.
If you wanna be pro choice,
if you wanna be pro abortion, fine.
But stop using women who have gone through miscarriages
and who have gone through loss
as a way to justify legalized abortion
across the board, at any time,
for any reason. It's dishonest and it is disgusting.